pag à sion à tout prix alors le
gouvernement a fait ce choix du couvre
feu étendu
je vous propose d'écouter jean castex
sur l'ensemble dû territoire
métropolitain
le couvre-feu s'appliquera à compter de
18 heures à partir de ce samedi et pour
au moins 15 jours
pourquoi ce choix il apparaît selon les
données disponibles à ce jour que cette
mesure a une efficacité sanitaires dans
les 15 premiers départements où le
couvre feu a été mis en oeuvre à 18
heures le 2 janvier dernier la hausse du
nombre de nouveaux cas y ait deux voire
trois fois plus faible que dans les
autres départements métropolitains comme
le montre la carte qui s'affiche à
l'écran dans son dernier avis reçus hier
soir et qui sera rendue publique très
rapidement le conseil scientifique a du
reste confirmé l'utilité du couvre-feu
dans la lutte contre la pandémie
alors ceci implique que les commerces
qui sont déjà très affectée par les
effets de la pandémie devront fermer
plus tôt ils ont été exhortés par un
jean castex à ouvrir durant la pause
déjeuner ou encore le dimanche 1 pour
combler le montet le manque à gagner
ils devront respecter des jauges très
précises
donc voici pour les commerces alors
pourquoi ce choix du couvre-feu et pas
dur confinement partielle ou totale
eh bien elle ne se produirait que si il
y avait une dégradation épidémique forte
selon un jean castex katia on attendait
également des annonces sur les
établissements scolaires
ah oui absolument et bien écoutez le
gouvernement veut absolument éviter la
fermeture des écoles
alors il y aura désormais encore plus de
dépistage et de contrôle avec des
dépistages justement sur place pour les
élèves le personnel les professeurs et
puis une autre annonce encore les
activités d'intérieur comme par exemple
le sport qu'elles soient scolaires ou
extra scolaires seront suspendus durant
plusieurs semaines
il s'agit également d'éviter le brassage
lors de la cantine donc les élèves
devront rester entre classes alors quand
même une bonne nouvelle partiel
encourage les étudiants qui souffrent de
graves difficultés psychologiques et
bien certains vont pouvoir reprendre les
cours il s'agit des td pour les
premières années en 2000 groupe à partir
du 25 janvier et pour les autres ce sera
au fur et à mesure avec un protocole
adapté et puis bien entendu jean castex
et olivier verront on tv compte évoquer
l'actualité du moment c'est à dire la
campagne vaccinale on écoute
conformément à notre stratégie de
priorisation des plus fragiles et un
accord avec les autorités scientifiques
et des associations de patients
j'ai décidé d'ouvrir dès lundi 18
janvier également la vaccination aux
personnes quel que soit leur âge
présentant une des pathologies
conduisant à un très haut risque de
formes graves de la maladie
plus de 700 centres de vaccination
seront ouverts lundi grâce à la
mobilisation conjointe de l'état des
élus locaux et des professionnels de
santé
alors il faut ajouter que dès demain les
plus de 75 ans pourront se faire
vacciner dans des centres en prenant
rendez vous sur le site ma santé pardon
le site sante.fr ou alors grâce à un
numéro vert voilà pour ce qui concerne
les vaccins et une objection objectif
d'un million de personnes vaccinées à la
fin janvier à 4 y at il eu d'autres
annonces importantes au cours de cette
longue conférence de presse
[Musique]
et oui en effet il y en a eu comme par
exemple des restrictions aux frontières
les voyageurs qui proviennent d'un pays
hors union européenne devront présenter
un test négatif pour entrer sur le
territoire français et puis dans ce
marasme une bonne nouvelle relative
dirons-nous des aides supplémentaires
pour les professions les plus touchés
pour les exploitants de restaurants de
celle de sport de discothèque
il y aura des z donc qui seront indexés
sur le chiffre d'affaires sans plafond
des des pluies il y a dans certains
contextes dans certains critères
d'appris en charge des charges fixes
comme la location
voilà ce qu'il faut retenir de cette
longue conférence de presse merci katia
technique dans les règles donc depuis le
ministère de la santé
la situation sanitaire est donc
maîtriser mais fragile dans le pays
selon gouvernement pour revenir sur ces
nouvelles mesures restrictives et aussi
de soutiens parce qu'il ya eu beaucoup
d'annoncés en sujet de l'industrie place
à notre décryptage avec nos invités
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec marie
george buffet députée pcf de
seine-saint-denis également on en
parlera avec vous marie george buffet
évidemment au rapporteur d'un rapport
sur les effets de la crise du coc vide
sur l'enfance et la jeunesse bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous yves blein député
la raim de la 14e circonscription du
rhône bonsoir à vous également enfin
christophe prudhomme porte parole de
l'association des médecins urgentistes
en france bonsoir et merci à tous les
trois d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france alors avant de vous faire réagir
sur cette longue conférence de presse et
les nouvelles annonces vous propose
d'écouter le premier ministre qui défend
sa stratégie globale face au co vide
les résultats de notre stratégie nous
place aujourd'hui dans une situation
comparative plus qu'honorable en europe
tant au niveau des taux d'incidence que
des taux de positivité des tests alors
marie george buffet le premier ministre
qui contre attaque parce qu'il avait
subi beaucoup de critiques ces derniers
temps mais il est plutôt satisfait de sa
stratégie de la stratégie de son
gouvernement la france fait en gros
mieux que nos voisins européens
je ne pense pas que l'époque soit ce pop
art et avec d'autres pays
l'important c'est d'être capable de
répondre à cette prise à cette pandémie
et de protéger des hommes et les femmes
qui vivent ceux ci la victoire
je suis particulièrement déçu des
annonces concernant le monde étudiant
franchement annoncé qu'il va y avoir une
rue une réunion de la conférence des
présidents d'université qui doit y avoir
une concertation était syndicat étudiant
pour envisager la reprise progressive
des cours en faculté on a l'impression
que tout cela en vain
après un temps infini ça aurait dû déjà
être pensée est réglée avant les
vacances de fin d'année les étudiants
sont allés internet at 10
le mans de précarité sociale de rupture
de la continuité pédagogique
on a l'impression que le gouvernement ne
prend pas la même la paix de mesure de
ce désarroi alors vous avez un petit peu
de vent c'est effectivement ces annonces
parce que alors on vend on parlait de
ses universités
c'était quelque chose de très attendu un
débat était consacré d'ailleurs aux
universités hier à l'assemblée nationale
qui vous concerne effectivement
particulièrement avec votre rapport je
voudrais d'abord qu'on revienne sur les
grosses annonces qui pour le coup
implique toute la france qui concerne
tous les français un couvre-feu à 18
heures qui sera mis en place à partir de
samedi pour moi quinze jours sur
l'ensemble dû territoire métropolitain
français
votre réaction christian prudhomme
on n'a pas choisi le confinement strict
nous on a choisi ce couvre-feu de 18h
plutôt satisfaisant ça va payer
écoutez je ne sais pas si ça va payer ce
qu'ils payent c'est une stratégie
globale vous savez ce la risée sur
confinement couvre feu n'est pas la
bonne solution vous savez le virus à sa
propre vie et je ne suis pas sûr que ce
soit le couvre-feu avancé à 18 heures
qui est fait que dans un certain nombre
de départements
l'incidence du nombre de cas positifs
diminue ce qui est clair c'est que nous
avons une arme qui est efficace si on le
voit dans un grand nombre de pays c'est
le dépistage avec l' isolement des
personnes contagieuses
or nous sommes toujours sur une mauvaise
pente concernant ce dépistage parce
qu'on isole pas assez on dépiste
beaucoup mais on isole pas voilà donc il
suffit pas de se targuer de faire
beaucoup de tests
quand ils veulent mais ne fonctionne pas
il faut savoir que le gouvernement n'a
pris une mesure qui est très efficace
pour les salariés qui est de supprimer
le jour de carence que il ya dix jours
ce jour de carence et ne faisait qu'un
certain nombre de personnes continuaient
à aller travailler
en attendant d'avoir le résultat de
leurs tests or la règle
c'est au moindre doute c'est de ne plus
aller travailler physiquement
quand on a un doute des codecs ont fait
le test
or un certain nombre de salariés pour ne
pas de perdre donc ce jour de carence
continuer à aller travailler en
attendant le résultat du test
et puis vous savez sur le vaccin ya
quand même des ratés au démarrage et moi
je n'ai pas compris pourquoi les
départements les plus touchés n'ont pas
été priorisés pour pouvoir disposer très
rapidement d'une vaccination de masse
dans ces départements
voyez donc la mettre sur le même plan
des départements où il ya besoin de
renforcer les mesures et puis d'autre
pour l'instant
eh bien on pourrait être donc avec des
mesures plus légère ça ne paraît pas
cohérent vous savez le virus n'a pas de
frontières et donc ce sont des régions
qui sont touchés plus que des pays or
depuis le début il ya eu qu une
coordination en europe chacun fait dans
son coin
démodé prend des mesures de confinement
de couvre-feu et cetera
il serait bien que l'on puisse adapter
ces mesures en fonction de l'urgence
dans les régions les plus contaminés
voilà donc aujourd'hui
simplement on a attendu trois jours
savez ce qui est assez énervant dans
cette épidémie
c'est que il faut attendre l'oracle
alors cette fois ci c'était le premier
ministre et on voit bien que il ya des
difficultés parce qu'on attend que le
premier ministre nous explique qu'il va
y avoir un numéro vert que finalement le
site dédié de santé publique ne
fonctionne pas bien et saturé et cetera
il serait bien que plutôt que d'attendre
l'oracle eh bien on met au travail
les services de l'état pour que et les
services 1re lien avec les collectivités
locales pour qu'on puisse avoir
effectivement des tests et un isolement
qui fonctionne et une vaccination qui
fonctionne et vous savez sur la
vaccination
eh bien il serait bien qu'on fasse
confiance au terrain et qu'on vaccine
dans les quartiers avec les médecins
avec les pharmaciens avec les
infirmières parce que c'est là qu'est
fectivement permettra de vacciner en
masse parce que les gens retrouveront la
confiance ces personnes qui connaissent
et donc jusqu'à présent c'est pas la
stratégie qui a été adoptée on va mettre
en place des seins
christophe prudhomme on va y revenir sur
ses vaccins va prendre les thèmes dans
l'ordre en attendant pour le moment pas
de troisième confinement le premier
ministre se laisse cette possibilité en
cas de dégradation de la situation alors
qu'en penser français des nouvelles
restrictions à ce couvre-feu à 18h
étendue à tout le territoire je vous
propose d'écouter ces quelques parisiens
interrogés dans la déjà c'est parce qu
en province est un peu plus simple qu'en
région parisienne puisqu'il ya les
contraintes du métro les horaires sont
différents la circulation les bouchons
donc voilà après si on est retraité mais
c'est pas contraignant mais pour des
actifs je pense que oui fera encore plus
de gens qui vont se retrouver aux mêmes
heures dans l'est dans les commerces
quoi donc ça va multiplier encore plus
moi je trouve ça un but qui vient encore
plus autant mieux faire au confinement
total parce que ça ne sert à rien à 20
heures c'est déjà dur à 18 heures ça
sera encore plus dure autant mieux et
nous recombine totalement ont restreint
questionnement on avance dans le temps
et en fin de compte
malheureusement
on fait des concessions et ça s'arrange
à mais en contraire on avance toujours
depuis remplir le couvre-feu de 18h
c'est une bêtise voilà parce qu on était
à 20h et maintenant nous font passer à
18 heures centre sert à rien ça sert à
rien du tout voilà c'est france est un
petit peu mitigés notamment sur la
notion de couvre-feu à 18 heures
certains auraient aimé à la limite qu'on
y aille franchement qui tarde à régler
les choses
il blanc vous vous êtes plutôt satisfait
alors je ne vais pas parler de demi
mesure dans ce cas un jugement de valeur
de ma part mais en tout cas voilà on ne
confirme pas mais on avance ce couvre
feu à toute la hat on le pays
oui je sais pas s'il faut parler de
satisfaction vrai dire je pense que la
tactique si on peut dire comme cela qui
est adopté par le gouvernement et je
vois pas quelles pourraient en être une
autre c'est de toute façon de s'adapter
à l'évolution de la situation et de
s'adapter au plus près de l'évolution de
la situation de ce que l'on constate
aujourd'hui c'est que clairement la
pandémie et est repartie elle est à un
niveau important moindre que dans
d'autres pays ce qui permet
effectivement d'être dans des mesures
moins contraignante on n'est pas dans un
confinement total mais on cherche
néanmoins à éviter le plus possible le
brassage de la population à des horaires
ou c'est pas absolument indispensable
parce qu'on doit aller au travail parce
qu'on doit aller à l'école c'est ce qui
est recherché tout en laissant la
possibilité au commerce de rester ouvert
puisque il faut bien que les personnes
des français puissent s'alimenter et
puissent faire leurs courses etc
mais en le faisant dans des volumes
horaires qu'ils fassent qu'on limite
encore une folle le brassage de la
population
quand on sait que mais on a constaté à
l'occasion des fêtes
c'est un des vecteurs de propagation du
virus donc satisfait je dirais qu'il ya
pas lieu de se satisfaire du
chose sûre réponse voilà adapter la
situation d'aujourd'hui
en tout cas il y avait un autre sujet
qui était sur toutes les lèvres le cas
des écoles puisqu'on sait depuis peu que
de plus en plus un les enfants sont
atteints par ce qu vie d'un 10 % pour
les moins de 10 ans selon une étude
récente de santé publique france
pourtant le gouvernement a décidé de ne
pas les fermer en c'était l'un des
objectifs de jean michel blanquer a
néanmoins il aura un protocole plus
strictes à la cantine vous propose
d'écouter tout d'abord le ministre de
l'éducation dès la semaine du 25 janvier
et travaux dirigés pourront donc
reprendre en demi-groupe pour les
étudiants de première année c'est une
étape sur ce chemin avant de pouvoir
réintégrer davantage d'étudiants les
protocoles d'accueil devront prévenir le
brassage des étudiants garantir les
règles de distanciation
ils devront éviter que les étudiants
restent sur site pour les pauses
méridiennes en lien avec les équipes du
ministère des solidarités et la santé
des dépistage individuel ou collectif
seront déployés des tests antigénique
seront mis à la disposition des services
de santé universitaire notre stratégie
de test prend un nouveau tour avec dès
le mois de janvier dans les écoles les
collèges et les hippies c'est une
possibilité massive de déploiement pour
plus d'un million de personnels et des
élèves pour accentuer notre surveillance
de la circulation du virus en milieu
scolaire et en complément de ce que nous
faisons déjà c'est-à-dire le traçage des
cas contacts ce qu'on appelle parfois le
contact racing va évidemment continuer
donc nous le mettons en place avec
chaque agence régionale de santé depuis
la rentrée comme vous le montre le
graphique que vous voyez à l'écran et
maintenant nous aurons non seulement ce
traçage donc qui continuera mais aussi
la possibilité pour certains
établissements d'avoir la venue d'une
équipe de dépistage de tous les
personnels
de tous les élèves sur place chaque fois
qu'il y aura trois cas de contamination
et puis il y aura aussi l'identification
de tous les personnels lycéens et
collégiens qui se verront donc proposer
un test dans les 48 heures dans ce type
d' hypothèse on a attendu donc le
ministre de l'éducation et ait
auparavant la ministre de l'enseignement
on reparlera des universités dans un
second temps marie george buffet c'est
une bonne chose on laisse les écoles
ouvertes vous justement je le disais qui
est rapporteur des conséquences
notamment sur la souffrance un des
enfants et des jeunes
sur les effets de la crise du coc vite
c'est quand même une bonne chose parce
que c'est vrai qu'on entendait les
pédiatres nous dire il faut que les
enfants restent à l'école si tu il faut
absolument maintenir les écoles ouvertes
des écoles les collèges les lycées
pourquoi parce que le confinement à des
montres et trois conséquences
extrêmement importantes d'abord une
conséquence de physique avec une prise
de poids
l'absence de mobilité la réactivité ont
diminué chez les enfants selon les
pédiatres des conséquences psychiques
parce que c'est pas facile pour un
enfant de perdre ce sujet de sociabilité
qu'il trouve à l'école d'abord avec les
professeurs mais aussi la vessie copa
ses copines qui sort de chez lui va vers
un autre monde et pratiquer des
activités physiques cette erreur et puis
conséquence au christ sur la continuité
pédagogique parce que selon que les
parents et des routes il y est rond
point de vue numérique pas simplement
les instruments mais la connaissance
mérite d'avoir conservé ou selon que des
parents étaient démunis par rapport à
cela
les enfants n'ont pas pu avoir la même
continuité pédagogique et je vais
jusqu'à aux enfants les plus en
difficulté j'ai pu j'ai rencontré les
familles et vous placez en hôtels dans
les hôtels sociaux
parfois il n'y a pas de wifi il n'y a
plus rien dans une thèse sociaux et les
enfants étaient en rupture vraiment au
niveau pédagogique oui donc il faut
vraiment maintenir les écoles verts on
trouve en effet des parades par rapport
à la cantine bright food et élargir la
coupure du midi multiplier les services
il faut qu'on trouve des solutions mais
il faut que l'école reste ouverte et
c'est pour cela aussi je pense que
toutes les universités réouvre très vite
le médecin vous êtes christian prudhomme
et est d'accord avec ce postulat on sait
que beaucoup de pays de nombreux pays
européens ont fermé leur école leur
école c'est le cas des éléments des
onglets également parce que je le disais
tout à l'heure le virus circule
davantage surtout avec ces nouvelles
souches très contagieuse c'était une
bonne chose et comme le dit marie-george
buffet de trouver la parade avec des
tests
et plus de restrictions notamment dans
les cantines écoutez il faut regarder
les chiffres
la mortalité chez les moins de 25 ans
est quasiment nul voila ea et même
jusqu'à 45 ans nous avons les chiffres
sur l'ensemble de l'année 2020 la
mortalité en france des moins de 45 ans
a diminué alors oui les jeunes peuvent
être vecteurs du virus
encore que les études montrent que
beaucoup d'enfants sont contaminés par
leurs parents donc il faut maintenir ces
écoles et jusqu'aux universités ouvertes
très largement en prenant des mesures
parce que les conséquences et la santé a
trois composantes physiques
psychologiques et sociales
or là y'a rien au niveau physique dans
cette population là ils n'ont pas de
conséquence par contre au niveau
psychologique et social c'est une
catastrophe
moi je peux vous dire je travaille au
samu de seine-saint-denis nous avons
régulièrement des étudiants au téléphone
qui présente des dépressions graves qui
sont au bout du rouleau et au niveau
social
je discutais récemment avec un étudiant
qui faisait de chauffeurs hubert pour
pouvoir survivre et qui cherchaient
désespérément un stage parce que vous
savez pour certaines formations il faut
des stages et il avait un diplôme qui
pourraient être utiles dans la période
en neurosciences
il demandait un stage comme attachés de
recherche clinique
il a eu un rendez-vous à l'assistance
publique on ne l'a même pas octroyer ce
stage voyez donc il ya un véritable
problème je pense que on se trompe
complètement vis-à-vis des jeunes il
faut privilégier aujourd'hui chez ces
jeunes le maintien le autant que
possible d'une vie normale d'une vie
sociale et les conséquences au niveau
psychologique le plus normale possible
c'est très important aujourd'hui d'être
particulièrement vigilants concernant
les conséquences vont être
catastrophiques au niveau de la santé
dans les mois et dans les années qui
viennent pour cette tranche de
population en tout cas le gouvernement a
autorisé la reprise par 2000 groupe 1 du
travail dans les
université ça ne vient pas un peu tard
yves blein cette voie là cette
autorisation parce que
les étudiants ont payé on vient
d'entendre un lourd tribut il ya eu
quand même deux tentatives de suicide
cette semaine à lyon est-ce que c'est
pas un peu trop tard vous habitiez
d'avoir dû à avoir un point de vue sur
la question de l'école peut-être avant
de celui de l'université je crois
effectivement que l'école est le dernier
lieu à fermer
marie george buffet indiqué des
problèmes de santé physique de santé
psychologique mais aussi la question du
décrochage scolaire qui est vraiment une
question importante la qualité de la
sociologie de la vie à l'école pour les
enfants en france je crois que
effectivement y compris d'ailleurs pour
la vie en famille on a vu dans la
première personne période de confinement
des tensions que le fait de garder des
enfants à la maison h 24 30 comme on y
peut aussi provoquer dans les familles
notamment dans les milieux modestes
celles qui ont des petits appartements
et qui vivent pas de séjours dans les
meilleures conditions
l'équipe est qu effectivement c'est sans
aucun doute une mesure qui était
absolument primordiale la question des
universités la ministre l'a indiqué le
25 janvier pourront reprendre les
travaux dirigés en présentiel en petits
groupes
on est très prudent sur la question
effectivement de la reprise à
l'université parce que les jeunes sont
des jeunes adultes qui commence à être
concernés par cette terrible épidémie et
qu'il faut à l'instar de ce que l'on
fait pour l'ensemble de la population
agir avec la plus grande prudence pour
les 8es que cette contamination se
répondent merci en tout cas tous les
trois on arrive malheureusement déjà à
l'issue de ce débat à noter que le
premier ministre a aussi affirmé que la
vaccination concerne est la priorité des
priorités pour sortir de cette crise et
annoncé que 2 700 centres de vaccination
ouverts dès lundi mais ce sera l'objet
débat merci à tous les trois d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur arte france
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous irons aux etats unis la chambre des
représentants le congrès en même s'est
prononcée hier en faveur d'une
destitution de donald trump est cette
fois dix élus républicains ont voté pour
prochain vote au sénat à partir du 20
janvier puis nous parlerons de
washington est ville sous haute tension
en attendant l'investiture de joba des
noms sera sur place avec un autre envoyé
spécial thomas bonnin
[Musique]
comment choisissez-vous un film un
projet un scénario un réalisateur avant
de choisir on ait choisi ce qui fait le
propre d'un acteur c'est de partager des
sentiments des idées des émotions
vous vous êtes vraiment dans le cinéma
de créateurs d'initiateur je crois que
le cinéma c'est comme la peinture c'est
comme le la littérature ça reste un art
déco maintenant c'est l'industrie qui
gagne mais du coup peut-être qu est-ce
qui va rester c'est que les films qui
seront de plus en plus fait pour le
cinéma et pas sur les grands réseaux
resteront des objets artistiques godard
qui disait cette chose si forte
quand on regarde la télévision en baisse
les yeux quand on va au cinéma enlève
les yeux tout est dit
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
[Applaudissements]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent la
haine en soi vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui une gauche que tous les
témoins de notre époque sont dans la
grande interview
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
20h30 heure française soit il est
bienvenu en direct sur rt france donald
trump devient le premier président de
l'histoire des états unis être deux fois
mis en accusation au congrès à une
semaine de la fin de son mandat à la
chambre des représentants a voté cette
nuit une procédure de destitution contre
le président sortant
il est accusé d'incitation à
l'insurrection lors de l'assaut de ses
partisans au capitole le 6 janvier et
détails avec mathilde romagnan un texte
historique
l'acte d'accusation contre donald trump
a été signé cette nuit par la présidente
démocrate de la chambre des
représentants nancy pelosi dominé par
les démocrates l'assemblée s'est
prononcée pour cette impeachment par 232
voix contre 190 est une conséquence
directe des violences commises au
capitole la semaine dernière par les
militants pro trump aujourd'hui de
manière bipartite la chambre a démontré
que personne n'est au-dessus de la loi
pas même le président des états unis que
donald trump est un danger évident et
immédiat pour notre pays et qu'une fois
de plus nous honorons ce serment de
protéger et de défendre la constitution
des états unis
que dieu nous vienne en aide le 6
janvier dernier des milliers de
partisans de donald trump ont envahi le
temple de la démocratie américaine
un chaos survenu juste après un discours
du président sortant dans lequel il
confirmé son refus de reconnaître la
victoire de joe biden cinq personnes
sont mortes au cours de ces événements
donald trump a déjà fait l'objet d'une
procédure d' impeachment déclenchée il
ya plus d'un an pour abus de pouvoir et
entrave à la bonne marche du congrès il
était alors accusé d'avoir fait pression
sur le président ukrainien pour ouvrir
une enquête contre le fils de joe biden
pour cette seconde procédure le contexte
politique est tout autre dix députés
républicains ont voté cette nuit
cette nouvelle
mises en accusation le président sortant
semble de plus en plus isolé dans son
propre camp il a posté une vidéo depuis
la maison blanche appelant à l'unité la
violence collective va à l'encontre de
tout ce en quoi je crois et de tout ce
que notre mouvement défend aucun de mes
véritables partisans ne pourrait être
favorable à la violence politique
aucun de mes vrais partisans ne pourrait
jamais manqué de respect aux forces de
l'ordre ou à notre grand drapeau
américain
aujourd'hui j'appelle tous les
américains à surmonter les passions du
moment et à s'unir en un seul peuple
américain choisissons d'aller de l'avant
unis pour le bien de nos familles de nos
communautés et de notre pays la
procédure d' impeachment est donc
formellement ouverte
ce sera au sénat de juger donald trump
il faudra les deux tiers des sénateurs
pour obtenir sa destitution le procès ne
devrait pas avoir lieu avant son départ
de la maison blanche le 20 janvier
prochain
et depuis la manifestation du 6 janvier
au capitole et awa chez hays washington
les autorités ont renforcé leurs
dispositifs de sécurité dans toutes les
villes on retrouve sur place notre
reporter thomas abonnés bonsoir ou
bonjour pour vous thomas quelle est
l'atmosphère sur place à washington on
imagine
il tendu fébrile à six jours de
l'investiture de joe biden
absolument stéphanie l'atmosphère très
tendue et vous allez en avoir la preuve
avec ces images de l'uqat eu à ses
membres
ces camions militaires de la garde
nationale qui sont déployés pour que
vous compreniez bien on est à plusieurs
centaines de mètres du capitole il est
impossible pour nous de s'en approcher
davantage puisque un périmètre de
sécurité très important a été déployé
notamment donc depuis cette
manifestation du 6 janvier avec des
palissades qui ont été dressés et donc
des militaires de la garde nationale qui
montent la garde nuitées jours ici pour
évidemment empêcher toute intrusion de
la part de manifestants il y a
énormément de militaires de la guerre
nationale qui sont arrivés ici à
washington et qui continuent d'arriver
on voit très régulièrement des quarts
arrivé avec à leur bord des dizaines de
soldats venus donc supplée les autorités
locales notamment la police du capitole
qui avaient été quelque peu débordé le 6
janvier dernier selon les autorités il y
aura environ 10000 membres de la garde
nationale pour cette journée du 20
janvier un chiffre qui pourrait même
être doublé en cas de nécessité
évidemment la crainte c'est de voir à
nouveau une manifestation violente se
déroulait ici dans la ville de
washington est une des conséquences de
cette forte affluence de soldats de la
garde nationale ici dans la capitale
fédérale
ce sont ces images qui circulent depuis
plusieurs heures sur les réseaux sociaux
où on voit des soldats de la garde
nationale en train de dormir à même le
sol au sein du capitole alors ces images
ont un peu choqué un certain nombre
d'internautes au point que le district
de columbia a publié un communiqué pour
apporter quelques précisions écouter
la police du capitole a réservé des
espaces pour le repos des gardes
nationaux en service entre leur tour de
garde
pour être clair ce n'est pas là qu'il
sont logés une fois leur service terminé
le travail de notre personnel de
sécurité s'organisent par poste afin
qu'il soit toujours vif et vigilants et
qu'ils puissent avoir des moments de
repos alors que d'autres assurent la
veille autre illustration de cette forte
affluence de membres de la garde
nationale ici dans la capitale fédérale
ce sont certains hôtels qui se sont
transformés en bases militaire improvisé
c'est le cas notamment de l'hôtel dans
lequel on loge en ce moment où il y a
plusieurs dizaines de soldats qui sont
stationnés qui sont logés ici en
attendant d'être déployés pour ces
prochains jours à thomas il faut dire
que l'inquiétude est forte après la
publication d'une note du fbi haye qui
fait état de menaces de manifestations
armés dans le pays pendant cette période
de transition présidentielle
[Musique]
oui c'est une note qui a été diffusé par
plusieurs médias américains ces derniers
jours où donc le fbi et les services de
renseignement expliquent qu'il y à des
menaces qui planent autour de cette
journée du 20 janvier et les jours qui
précèdent avec des manifestations
violentes qui pourraient avoir lieu
notamment ici dans la ville de
washington avec des individus
potentiellement armé qui pourraient
vouloir venir perturber cette journée de
passation il est important de préciser
que dans le district de columbia où on
est il n'y a levé le port d'armes n'est
pas autorisée il faudra donc voir si un
certain nombre de contrôles seront mises
en place pour empêcher tout individu
armé de sa prochaine un peu trop près du
capitole en attendant les autorités
recommande très fortement aux habitants
de ne pas se rendre dans le centre-ville
lorsqu'on arrive dans la ville de
washington à l'arrivée de cette ville il
y à des panneaux lumineux qui expliqué
qu'ils enjoignent les habitants à ne pas
se rendre dans le centre-ville pour
cette semaine qui arrive et puis on
notera aussi que la plateforme airbnb a
annulé toutes ses réservations ici dans
le centre ville de washington pour
justement ne pas permettre à de
potentiels manifestants violents de
venir perturber cette journée du 20
janvier
il faut également noter que cette menace
ne plane pas uniquement autour de la
ville de washington puisque selon la
même note du fbi haye
cette menace de manifestations violentes
plane également sur les 50 états des
états unis avec des manifestations qui
pourraient se dérouler près dé capital
de chaque état et donc les autorités
locales sont en train d'être à pied
d'oeuvre en ce moment pour mettre en
place des dispositifs de sécurité un peu
partout dans le pays
vous l'aurez compris à six jours
maintenant de la passation de pouvoirs
et malgré l'appel au calme
r de donald trump les etats unis sont
actuellement en alerte maximale merci
thomas bonnin en direct de washington et
donald trump et les réseaux sociaux à
présent le patron de twitter ne regrette
pas d'avoir banni le président sortant
mais reconnaît je cite un précédent
dangereux alors que donald trump juge
que ces réseaux qui l'ont banni font une
erreur catastrophique
le patron de twitter lui est revenu
aujourd'hui dans une série de tweets sur
les événements qui ont conduit à la
suspension de ce conte jack dorsey
considère que c'était la bonne décision
mais reconnaît également un échec
je pense que c'était la bonne décision
pour twitter nous avons été confrontés à
une situation extraordinaire et
intenable qui nous a obligés à
concentrer toutes nos actions sur la
sécurité publique
les dommages causés hors ligne par des
discours en ligne sont manifestement
réel et c'est ce qui motive avant tout
notre politique et son application
cela dit le fait de devoir interdire un
conte a des conséquences réelles est
importante
bien qu'il existe des exceptions claire
et évidente
j'ai le sentiment qu'une interdiction
est un échec de notre part à promouvoir
une conversation scène ce doit être un
moment pour nous de réfléchir à nos
activités et à l'environnement qui nous
entoure et pour évoquer cette période
cruciale aux etats unis nous sommes en
direct depuis new york avec jean-claude
gruffat remet d'affaires
franco-américain c'est notre rubrique vu
de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir jean claude gruffat merci et
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
avoir finalement ne parle que de donald
trump
ces derniers jours alors même qu'il est
béni des réseaux sociaux censure entre
guillemets qui finalement est
contre-productif pour ses détracteurs
écoutez c'est trop tôt pour avoir un
jugement définitif sur le sujet je
préfère ne pas prendre position à cet
égard il est toujours regrettable de
voir que la liberté d'expression n'est
pas protégé parfois sa plate forme de
liberté d'expression peuvent être
dangereuses donc c'est une décision qui
a été prise par les réseaux sociaux qui
sont des réseaux privés et donc ça n'est
pas une décision publique ça n'est pas
une décision qui remet en cause le
premier amendement de la constitution
américaine quel droit à la parole qui
vous savez beaucoup plus libérale qu'en
europe puisque ici on peut dire
pratiquement tout alors qu'en europe il
ya beaucoup de contraintes en
particulier tout ce qui peut être
controversé le racisme l'antisémitisme
toute forme de discrimination ici on
mange et quand je me souviens après le
11-septembre d'avoir vu des bancaires
des gens qui circulaient dans la rue en
dix ans et les juifs qui l'ont fait en
france vous avez été mis en prison
immédiatement ici les gens regardaient
en disant ce sont des anormaux
ils ont droit de dire ce qu'ils veulent
même si c'est une aberration sa savante
encore plus
finalement le geste assez inédit efforts
des réseaux sociaux de bannir
donald trump a
des réseaux même le président de twitter
on l'a vu admis que cela crée un
précédent dangereux il parle même d'
échec il ya risque finalement donald
trump devienne une sorte de martyrs pour
ses partisans et qu'il fédère encore
davantage vous avez raison ce qui est en
train de se passer c'est que j'allais
dire toute une partie du de ceux des
gens qui soutenaient et rome qui ont
voté pour lui
rappelez-vous qu'il a eu cette fois en
2016 s'il avait plus de 60000 on voit
cette fois il en lice 74 millions donc
il ya beaucoup de gens qui m'ont soutenu
qui ont voté pour le gall élections mais
depuis l'élection
la contestation des résultats et surtout
la manière dont il a contesté les
résultats sans avoir de fait précis pour
justifier les accusations de fraude
n'ont pas été toujours été reçu de
manière très j'avais dit il ya peu
d'enthousiasmé
parce que là les américains sont des
gens qui sont prêts à entendre tous les
arguments mais la fraude n'a jamais été
prouvée et donc on peut dire beaucoup de
choses sur les halles les dernières
élections les élections ont été gagnés
par babel est donc tout ceci s'est fait
dans les formes le collège électoral
s'est réuni le 14 décembre
le congrès s'est réuni le 6 janvier
c'est à cette occasion d'ailleurs qu' on
a eu les manifestations et l'invasion du
capitole et les american entraînera le
véhicule cela donc il reste maintenant
j'allais dire un noyau dur des lecteurs
qui continue à penser que les élections
ont été frauduleuses et que dans un
certain nombre d'états il ya eu des des
malversations alors que ceci n'a jamais
été pourrait en revanche j'allais dire
l'establishment républicain et on l'a vu
puisque des gens qui ont soutenu 30
pendant tout son mandat
qu'il s'agisse du vice président de
penske il s'agit du patron des
républicains à la chambre kevin
mccaffrey qu'il s'agisse du patron des
républicains qui est toujours président
du sénat pour quelques jours
mich mccomas ou qu'il s'agisse de
l'italie la fille de dee jay lee
l'ancien vice-président de bouche qui
est la troisième personne dans la
hiérarchie républicaine au congrès tous
ces gens là on dit que les élections
étaient terminées
et qu'elle avait été bien dix par balle
donc on a maintenant clairement dans
l'establishment républicain qui se
dégage de 3 vous l'avez rappelé dix
parlementaires à la chambre ont voté
l'inpi semaine tu hier et je pense que
s'il ya un procès et ce procès
interviendra à partir du 10 du 19
puisque le sénat est en récession en ce
moment s'il ya un procès il et il est
vraisemblable qu'un nombre significatif
de républicains au sénat vote rond pour
une pitch 3 palancade dernière fois un
seul mitt romney l'ancien candidat en
2012 avaient voté sur un des chefs
d'inculpation est-ce qu'il est
souhaitable selon vous jean-claude
gruffat justement qu'il soit destitué
donald trump parce qu'on imagine qui a
forcément un calcul politique de la part
des démocrates qui souhaite à tout prix
éviter qu'ils ne se représente en 2024
écoutez là je ne suis pas complètement
d'accord avec vous je pense que
l'intérêt des démocrates c'est de
laisser trois se représenter parce que
c'est un facteur de division du parti
républicain maintenant et donc si tu
rates n'est pas un avantage principal de
son de sa condamnation dans le cadre de
l'inpi semaine par le sénat serait un
vote accessoires qui le rendrait
inéligible à tout mandat électif
s'il est inéligible il peut pas se
représenter donc à ce moment-là son
électorat devra se reporter sur d'autres
ça ne veut pas dire des républicains
nécessairement l'emporteront mais en
tout cas un facteur de division du camp
républicain va disparaître en revanche
s'il est en mesure de se représenter les
choses peuvent changer il a encore un
électorat qui est tout à fait
significative même si encore une fois
les dirigeants du parti républicain se
dégage de lui et se différencie par
rapport à lui il a dans l'électorat des
gens qui lui sont attachés même s'ils
sont pas portés nécessairement à la
violence et à l'insurrection et à
l'attentât il ya quelques jours jean
claude gruffat on parlait encore de
donald ramequins
voilà d'un mouvement le tropisme qui
allait s'installer dans le paysage
américain ont décrit désormais en tout
cas les correspondants sur place
décrivent le président sortant comme un
homme seul dans son bureau ovale que
plus personne n'appelle est-ce que c'est
fini pour donald trump
je crois que si vous voulez dans la
mesure où il n'est il va avoir
lorsque ces fonctions se termine le 20
il aura à régler toute une série de
problèmes personnels il ya toute une
série de contentieux qui affecte son
beau il a perdu un certain nombre de
contrats récemment à new york il a perdu
aussi d'un contrat pour un 3 modes gosse
extrêmement important qui devait être
une source de revenus pour lui sa banque
principale de tchibanga sorte a déclaré
qu'elle ne financerait plus ces projets
il ya 400 millions de dettes à
refinancer dans les 18 mois pour le
groupe
il a un certain nombre de trois ces
personnels pour des agressions notamment
sexuelles donc il a beaucoup de choses à
gérer une fois qu'il ne sera plus aux
affaires
et je pense que il n'y aura plus
beaucoup de temps pour faire de la
politique en tout cas dans l'immédiat
en revanche et c'est vrai qu'il a
toujours un électorat qui nous sera
attaché mais cet électorat on l'a bien
vu cet électorat qui ne se mobilise pas
lorsqu'il n'est pas sur ground sur le
bulletin de vote c'est ce qu'on a vu
avec les élections en géorgie ya une
semaine
cet électorat peu à peu disparaître ou
alors sera récupéré par d'autres
personnes qui auront peut être un profil
plus traditionnels d'hommes politiques
des gens comme pelouse
le sénateur cause ou d'autres qui se
sont exprimés ces derniers temps et qui
cherche clairement à récupérer le
tropisme sans avoir donc peut-être enfin
ces élites est tout simplement parce
qu'on voit que ivanka trump en ont fait
un petit peu des sanctions la fille
chérie
préférez de donald trump qui va assister
le 20 janvier à l'investiture contre
l'avis de son père on on en parle on
parle aussi voilà de son gendre de son
fils ce qu'il faut ça toi rendra à voir
émerger les héritiers de dynasties trump
non moi je n'y crois pas peut-être que
certains d'entre eux un de ses fils sa
fille peut-être peuvent être candidats
des élections on dit qu yvan cap pour
être candidat à une élection sénatoriale
en floride ça c'est une possibilité mais
de là à se positionner pour être le
successeur à la présidence je n'y crois
pas on a bien vu que les tentatives qui
ont lieu aux états unis de famille
dynastique il s'agit des bouchauds des
clinton ça n'a jamais été très noir les
américains ne sont pas tous deux
monarchistes
merci beaucoup jean claude greff armes
d'affaires franco-américain nous avoir
donné votre point de vue en direct des
états unis à six jours donc de cette
investiture de joe biden qui va
certainement se passer dans un climat de
haute tension mercier vos dons le reste
de l'actualité au parent à présent on
tunisie il y a dix ans le président ben
ali a été chassé du pouvoir par la rue
des millions tunisien inspiré à plus de
démocratie un avenir meilleur des
espérances qui ces dernières années ont
cédé leur place à la colère et à
l'amertume le bilan de la révolution du
jasmin avec ben hassen chébili et their
head nasri après des semaines de
soulèvement à travers toute la tunisie
c'est ici au coeur de la capitale
tunisienne sur l'avenue habib bourguiba
que des centaines de milliers de
tunisiens s'étaient donné rendez vous
pour célébrer cette victoire le départ
du président zine el abedine ben ali
après 23 ans de pouvoir alors dix ans
après que reste-t-il de cette journée
historique que sont devenus les rênes et
surtout les espoirs d'une vie meilleure
de tout un peuple tunisien
comme beaucoup de jeunes tunisiens
jawher militante de la première heure
s'interroge sur son avenir
il y a dix ans pourtant elle faisait
partie de ceux qui fêtait le changement
politique
après des semaines de mobilisation et
d'affrontements avec la police
mère d'un petit garçon de 4 ans cette
jeune fonctionnaire de l'éducation
nationale ne veut pas perdre espoir même
si tous les voyants de l'économie sont
au rouge
j'étais tellement heureuse de cette
révolution je n'arrivais pas à y croire
qu'enfin le peuple tunisien décide de se
soulever car moi mon engagement ne date
pas de la révolution j'étais déjà engagé
politiquement contre le système
j'écrivais sur les réseaux sociaux
j'étais très souvent censurés j'ai même
été blessé par balle durant les
premières heures du soulèvement
j'ai eu beaucoup d'occasions de quitter
mon pays même avant le départ de ben ali
mais pour moi ça a toujours été une
option inconcevable ici c'est chez moi
et c'est ici que je veux vivre auprès de
mes amis de mes proches et de la famille
et que mon fils grandisse ici dans son
pays
a sidi bouzid épicentre du printemps
arabe
le coeur ne semble pas être à la fête
pour ce dixième anniversaire de la
révolution
les rêves d'une grande partie de la
population reste plombée par une crise
économique et sociale sans précédent en
tunisie
le taux de chômage avoisine les 15 % et
atteint même 30 % dans les régions les
plus touchées comme le gouvernorat de
sidi bouzid la tunisie mais plus un pays
la tunisie demeure entre les mains d'une
poignée de corrompus de malfrats et de
voleurs à sidi bouzid
les gens n'en peuvent plus on a atteint
un point de non retour
nous n'avons pas le coeur à la fête
nous sommes en deuil depuis dix ans et
chaque année sidi bouzid pleure sa
révolution
et cette colère est d'autant plus
palpable chez ceux qui étaient prêts à
sacrifier leur vie pour un avenir
meilleur où elle se souvient de ce mois
de janvier 2011
opposants et militants il avait été
arrêté puis torturé par les forces de
l'ordre pour ses engagements et ses
prises de position anti benaddi
aujourd'hui il déplore un recul des
quelques progrès enregistrés le 5
janvier j'étais étudiant à sousse et
c'est là que des manifestations ont
éclaté
on n'est qu'aux événements qui avaient
éclaté à sidi bouzid et kasserine
ceux qui ont fait la révolution que nous
connaissons tous aujourd'hui à l'aube la
police a frappé la porte de chez moi m'a
traîné hors de mon lit pour me conduire
au commissariat
j'ai passé 48 heures en garde à vue les
6 et 7 janvier 2011
quarante huit heures de torture que vous
ne pouvez même pas imaginer
j'ai été frappée suspendu la tête en bas
brûlé avec des cigarettes et j'en passe
le lendemain je terminais en prison si
beaucoup semblent avoir baissé les bras
il demeure positif il veut toujours
croire au renouveau
dix ans après le mouvement qui avait
réveillé les consciences dans le monde
arabe
parmi toutes nos revendications la seule
chose qu'on a gagné c'est la liberté
d'expression et même cette seule
victoire reste remise en cause jour
après jour tant qu'il resterait une
cause à défendre
il restera des gens pour lutter et la
victoire finira par arriver peut-être
pas notre génération mais celle d'après
notre devoir est de nous accrocher à nos
droits et lutter pour il n'y a aucune
raison de perdre espoir
à la fin la justice triomphe toujours
impossible aujourd'hui de ne pas
ressentir ce pessimisme ambiant et ce
sentiment de désespérance largement
partagé par la jeunesse tunisienne
à l'heure où certains ont préféré la
voie de l'immigration clandestine ou
celle de l'économie informelle
d'autres veulent encore y croire pour
qu'enfin germer les fruits d'une
révolution dans espérer
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous reviendrons sur les dernières
annonces de jean castex ouvre feu
généralisé à partir de 18 heures dès
samedi car la situation est maîtrisée
mais fragile en france et puis direction
la péninsule ibérique également le
portugal qui seront confine demain les
régions espagnoles elles durcissent les
mesures face à la flambée des quatre co
vide
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre la peuplent
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du public
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas d'oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
une part de l'afrique comme d'un
continent en perpétuelle de son
dysfonctionnement actuel tient à
l'absence de redistribution à la
population par des dirigeants qui ont
une fâcheuse tendance à tout garder pour
les pays occidentaux ont favorisé cette
dérive en encourageant le maintien au
pouvoir de politiciens de plus en plus
âgés pour assurer la stabilité des pays
et des sourires
elles ont eu la prétention de croire que
les valeurs qu'elle défend des est
imposé par la force dans leur conquête
était universel dans cette terre des
possibles où s'esquissent les figures du
monde à venir
il faut changer notre logiciel et
arrêtez de dénigrer le faire à
l'africaine en octroyant au management à
l'anglo-saxonne
[Musique]
ce qu'on attend un peu de vous c'est les
idées pour en sortir est votre jugement
notamment de la façon dont cette crise
est gérée ce qui a été montré au cours
de la gestion de cette crise c'est le
déficit d'anticipation pour moi la
politique c'est d'abord d'être efficace
dès qu'un manque de cohérence
il ya il ya un manque de fiabilité il ya
un manque de confiance faut vite
retrouver la confiance vous considérer
aujourd'hui que que la france a été plus
mauvaise que beaucoup de nos pays
étrangers nous sommes le pays qui a
inventé les vaccins avec pasteur dont la
réactivité française n'a pas été à la
hauteur de notre réputation tout le
monde a vu que dès le mois de juillet
les chinois vacciner pourquoi est-ce
qu'on a attendu si longtemps
la question est de savoir comment est-ce
qu'on va retrouver un équilibre en
faisant en sorte que les épreuves que
nous subissons actuellement deviennent
des forces et non pas des handicaps
durable
[Musique]
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française
c'était après les attentats du 11
septembre et quand on vient vous voir et
qu'on vous dit ben écoutez vous avez de
la première femme qui allait rentrer
dans ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu que voilà c'est fini pour moi
est ce que ça remet en armes
tout est passé dans ma tête est ce que
vous avez appris de ces profils
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion le profil
vient toujours de la misère sociale
quand on écoute comme ça du malheur mais
quel est le rapport avec la réducation
mais c'est la radicalisation
il faut que nous reprenions la place
dans le cerveau des enfants et de la
jeunesse
[Musique]
le royaume-uni va-t-il sortir gagnant du
bric site
nous allons rester voisins et amis de
l'union européenne mais faisons partie
de l'europe
rien ne va changer cela maintenant
qu'ils sont sortis c'est là que les
choses vont commencer c'est pas un point
final du tout les choses commencent au
contraire plutôt que de finir un éclair
il est clair que bien qu lieux souhaite
un partenaire très puissant mieux
exporte bien plus vers le royaume uni
comme vous l'avez dit que le royaume uni
vers lui il faut bien comprendre que
c'est pour la circulation des biens et
sur la production bien si nous qui
sommes perdants c'est les européens
le crime est tellement épouvantable que
je pense qu'une partie de l'église mais
comme une partie de la société ne veut
pas le voir de 1950 à aujourd'hui le
travail de la commission a permis
d'identifier trois mille victimes 1500
agresseurs ces chiffres sont forcément
très en deçà de la réalité puisque des
victimes sont décédées des victimes ne
peuvent pas parler peut-être ne
parleront jamais ça montre cette
tragédie qui lie à un système au tour
c'est-à-dire comment des agresseurs ont
ils pu agresser 10/20 parfois trente ans
nous sommes loin du bout du chemin à
vous savez des institutions se réforment
lentement l'église peut être encore plus
lentement je ne sais pas mais en tout
cas je pense que la prise de conscience
est fait de tels scandales de tels
drames de telles tragédies dans la vie
oblige à la vérité
comment as tu fait de notre pas
seulement le cinéma
ils sont le cinéma
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
charles pathé a le génie des affaires
léon gaumont est un ingénieur surdoué
ces deux hommes que tout oppose et se
sont forgé une destinée commune dans une
perpétuelle surenchère ils ont bâti
chacun leur empire et dominer le monde
[Musique]
et
à 21h heure française soyez les
bienvenus en direct sur arte france
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
jeudi 14 janvier
cet acte et couvre feu généralisé à
partir de 18h pour l'ensemble du
territoire il démarre samedi pour au
moins 15 jours une logique préventive
alors que la france se maintient sur un
plateau élevé que le ou les variants
reste très menaçants vigilance renforcée
dans les écoles avec davantage de
dépistage la campagne vaccinale
elle se poursuit c'est la priorité des
priorités pour la sortie martèle le
premier ministre
[Musique]
l'europe au creux de la vague à côté
ibérique re confinement dès demain du
portugal au moins pendant un mois
l'espagne elle voit ses régions mettre
en place de nouvelles mesures
restrictives outre-rhin d'autorités
sanitaires souhaitent que les
restrictions soient renforcées alors que
l'allemagne enregistre aujourd'hui un
nombre record de décès un gala merkel ne
cache pas son pessimisme et souhaite des
restrictions plus larges
face à la virulence de la pandémie la
vaccination entre le co vite s'accélère
dans le monde plus de 30 millions de
personnes ont déjà reçu leur injection
il en est des milliards d'autres avec
signer un marché gigantesque donc pour
les labos qui se livrent une concurrence
sans merci mais aussi un outil
d'influencé unique pour les étapes
parfois les épaules la géoéconomie des
vaccins ces deux thèmes de l'édito échos
ce soir de j'accepte ya
les cnil souhaite interdire l'usagé de
drones avec caméra par les forces de
l'ordre et cela jusqu'à ce qu'un cadre
normatif soit mis en place précise t
elle le conseil d'état avait déjà
ordonné en décembre de ne pas recourir
aux drones pour surveiller les
manifestations dans un communiqué le
ministère de l'intérieur prend acte de
cette décision dont il respectera les
terres mais souligne l'article 22 de la
loi sécurité global prévoit cette
interdiction
[Musique]
grande conférence de presse donc ce soir
de l'exécutif sur la situation sanitaire
en fin d'après-midi le gouvernement a
annoncé plusieurs nouvelles mesures pour
freiner l'épidémie
alors que retenir de ces annonces ce
point complet avec quentin voeckler
l'information était attendue par les
français
elle est désormais officielle le
gouvernement a confirmé ce jeudi
après-midi la généralisation du
couvre-feu à partir de 18h sur
l'ensemble du territoire
cette mesure entrera en vigueur dès
samedi et pour une durée minimum de 15
jours il apparaît selon les données
disponibles à ce jour que cette mesure a
une efficacité sanitaires dans les 15
premiers départements où le couvre feu a
été mis en oeuvre à 18 heures le 2
janvier dernier la hausse du nombre de
nouveaux cas y ait deux voire trois fois
plus faible que dans les autres
départements métropolitains comme le
montre la carte qui s'affiche à l'écran
un temps évoqué un confinement le
week-end en plus du couvre-feu la
semaine n'a pas été retenu par
l'exécutif pour autant un nouveau
confinement généralisée n'est pas exclue
dans les prochaines semaines je veux
être parfaitement clair avec vous si
nous constatons dans les prochains jours
une dégradation épidémique forte nous
serions conduit à décider sans délais
d'un nouveau confinement
car nous devons comme nous n'avons cessé
de le faire depuis le début de cette
crise nous préparer à toute éventualité
du côté des écoles chaque classe mangera
chacune son tour afin d'éviter le
brassage des élèves dans les cantines
parallèlement les pratiques sportives
scolaires et extrascolaires en intérieur
sont désormais interdites pour les
mineurs
du côté des universités la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur a annoncé une
reprise très progressive des cours en
présentiel
nous devons permettre aux étudiants de
renouer le contact en présentiel avec
leurs enseignants il est impératif que
nous puissions progressivement tracer
ensemble ce chemin qui nous permettra de
passer d'une majorité d'enseignement en
distance y ait là une majorité
d'enseignement en présentiel dès la
semaine du 25 janvier
les travaux dirigés pourront donc
reprendre en demi groupe pour les
étudiants de première année c'est une
étape sur ce chemin avant de pouvoir
réintégrer davantage d'étudiants au
sujet des secteurs de la culture de la
restauration et du sport aucun
changement n'a été annoncée théâtres
bars musées restaurants ou encore salles
de sport garderont leur rideau baissé
jusqu'à nouvel ordre
enfin la propagation du variant
britanniques continuent d'inquiéter le
gouvernement désormais les voyageurs
venant de pays hors union européenne
devront obligatoirement présenter un
test pcr négatif de -2 72 heures pour
entrer sur le territoire français par
les airs ou par la mer
ces voyageurs devront également
s'engager sur l'honneur à s'isoler sept
jours à leur arrivée puis passer un
nouveau test pcr à l'issue de cette
période et ce couvre-feu 18 heures
annoncée par jean castex a évidemment
fait réagir la classe politique
française vous propose d'écouter
certaines de ces réactions que de temps
perdu par pure idéologie pour maîtriser
nos frontières tous les pays qui ont
maîtrisé rapidement leurs frontières
s'en sortent beaucoup mieux que nous
toujours rien sur la liberté et
l'autonomie des médecins frustré de ne
pas pouvoir prescrire à leur passion les
médicaments qui leur apparaissent
efficace pour soigner les malades
c'est insensé satisfait de voir que le
premier ministre a répondu positivement
à l'exigence d'un test pcr négatif pour
toutes les personnes qui souhaitent
venir en france hors union européenne
mesure que j'avais demandée pour
notamment protéger notre territoire de
nice côte d'azur
l'accompagnement sanitaire et sociale
nécessite l'embauché de 50 à 70 mille
personnes les jeunes cherchent du
travail proposons leur de participer à
la lutte contre le virus
monsieur v confinement annonce le
couvre-feu à 18 heures partout ne seront
plus nombreux à nous concentrer dans les
lieux communs transport magasins sur des
créneaux plus court
ces nouvelles trouvailles perpétuelle
sont insupportables une solution la
rotation unique annonce réelle
un couvre-feu à 18 heures dont personne
ne comprend l'utilité
vous le voyez le moment où on
s'agglutine rats tous pour faire nos
courses et dans les transports avant
l'heure fatidique est toujours rien sur
la crise sociale
la détresse de la jeunesse transport
bondé avant 18h magasin pris d'assaut le
week-end castex persiste dans l'erreur
et renouvelle des mesures inefficaces
pour notre économie
une autre voie est possible soins des
malades masques ffp2 pour les plus
fragiles et est co vide et pour en
parler nous sommes avec frédéric
jeanjean secrétaire général de l'union
des métiers des industries de
l'hôtellerie des bouches du rhône
bonsoir frédéric jeanjean merci d'être
avec nous on imagine que vous êtes j'ai
suivi cette très longue et conférence de
presse de jean castex et pourtant pas
beaucoup de mots pour vous les
restaurateurs toujours pas de date
en tout cas de réouverture votre
réaction
écoutez vous savez de toute façon qu'il
n'y aurait pas de réouverture possible
dans la posture du gouvernement monsieur
delfraissy l'avait dit on a bien compris
que de toute façon le gouvernement ne
sert qu'un être porte parole de monsieur
delfraissy depuis quelques temps nous on
avait fait des propositions
les propositions censées évidemment pour
des technocrates c'est quelque chose de
compliqué c'est selon lui ces
propositions censées c'était de z sommes
donc partis la france dans le sud y fait
pas trop trop froid on peut mettre nos
terrasses à disposition pour que les
gens puissent manger ou de s'agglutiner
sur des bancs au soleil là où ils le
peuvent de manger un peu n'importe
comment de se regrouper dans des bureaux
c'est aussi le cas dans l'établissement
on respecte protocole sanitaire des
gestes barrières
je rappelle quelque chose de très simple
le cas il rappelle que nous avions mis
en place personne d'autre de l'ami en
mis en oeuvre la grande distribution les
centres commerciaux les gens circulent
cercle utile c'est normal alors que chez
nous il était à distance et ils avaient
laissé leurs coordonnées
nous sommes les seuls endroits où ça a
été fait et maintenant ce n'est plus le
cas dans les transports en commun il
pourrait y avoir la possibilité avec des
smartphones de se faire europe de se
faire identifier
ça pourrait être la possibilité ça c'est
la première chose la deuxième chose nous
avons très bien que nous ne pourrons
reprendre une activité normale qu'à
partir du
mais pour nous il y aura une immunité
collective que ça passe par la
vaccination que on se rend compte que ça
tarde que ça met du temps on voit que
par exemple israël est arrivé ils ont
compilé tout le monde ils ont dit voilà
on confie tout le monde pendant un
certain temps et on va vacciner pendant
cette période-là eh bien ça produit des
résultats des effets et ils ont un
objectif auquel avril pour pouvoir se
remettre au travail pour pouvoir ouvrir
donc là pour l'instant
qu'est ce qu'on a on nous fait cette
annonce mais ça fait depuis le mois de
décembre qu'on savait qu'après les fêtes
de fin d'année il y aurait une poussée
épidémique que on allait alors nous
confirmait ce qu'ont annoncé aujourd'hui
que les gens moi parce que c'est
intéressant ce que vous nous dites vous
avez raison voilà il serait là à
vacciner 20% de sa population déjà ils
ont payé plus cher
le vaccin vous en voulez à quoi à
l'europe parce qu entre parenthèses les
voisins européens c'est pas mieux les
restaurants sont fermés chez eux aussi
c'est cette lenteur européenne qui
posent problème selon vous on la lenteur
et les parts au pnl et technocratique
vous faut pas se leurrer nous avons des
hauts fonctionnaires en france dans des
énarques et puis on a aussi des hauts
fonctionnaires à bruxelles
la thèse accidentelle et européennes ont
elles et européennes mais la difficulté
derrière elle et ensuite sur les prises
de décision localement sur le territoire
il peut y avoir des possibilités quand
je vous parle d'ouvrir les terrasses et
les terrans se chauffer bien évidemment
parce qu'on est quand même en hiver ça
c'est pas l'europe qui va le décider
quand on parle quand on voit que les
restaurants d'entreprises restent
ouverts où les gens vont s'agglutiner
c'est pas l'europe qui intervient là
dessus
quand on voit que les aides sont
décaissés la partir de demain a encore
demandé les aides pour le mois de
décembre mais les loyers les crédits
tous a déjà été payée prélevés sur nos
comptes pour ce qu'ils entendent
d'argent pour ceux qui ont peu d'argent
de toute façon c'est rejeter est ce que
les aides qui vont arriver doivent
servir à payer des ajouts pour les
banques c'est aussi une autre question
alors je vous ai marre je me repose
justement frédéric jeanjean des côtés
bruno le maire le ministre de l'économie
qui s'exprimait sur ces points fait ste
mans je veux simplement confirmer que
nous maintiendrons en janvier les
exonérations de cotisations sociales
et les aide au paiement des cotisations
sociales qui ont été mises en place en
décembre
l'objectif est simple zéro charges
sociales pour les entreprises qui sont
fermées ou qui sont lourdement pénalisés
dans les secteurs liés à l'hôtellerie le
café la restauration le sport frédéric
jeanjean tout de même savourer conforte
un petit peu oui mais ça fait des mois
qu'on l'attend ça fait des mois qu'on
attende tout ça est con on attend que
les des choses concrètes des
propositions qu'on a fait on trouve un
écho et à chaque fois il faut lever le
temps il faut engager un bras de fer il
faut il faut vraiment se mettre dans des
situations pas possibles pour pouvoir
arriver à obtenir gain de cause
là l'heure actuelle on nous annonce
comment pouvoir repousser le
remboursement du prêt garanti par l'état
dans l'est de ce report
c'est à dire qu'au lieu de rembourser en
cinq ans je rembourse hollande quatre
ans est-ce que ça va aider nos
entreprises à redémarrer
est-ce que ça va aider la trésorerie je
ne le crois pas je vais vous donner un
exemple très concret mon établissement
sur l'année 2020 puisque en fin d'année
on a tiré le chiffre d'affaires j'ai
perdu deux cent soixante deux mille
euros les aides de l'état puisque on dit
que les restaurateurs sont inondés
l'argent de la part de l'état sur 200
jeux sur ces plus de 250 2000 euros que
nous avons perdu nous avons vu un peu
moins de 30000 euros dead
ça c'est du concret ils voudront perdu
53 % de notre chiffre d'affaires
alors aujourd'hui il ya évidemment
beaucoup de patrons de restaurants de
bars qui sont désespérés
vous vous êtes au combat mais certains
n'ont même pas la force de s'exprimer
d'ailleurs un patron de bar s'est
suicidé dans les vosges
emmanuel macron lui a rendu hommage et
promet que les restaurants ouvriront dès
que possible un commentaire
un commentaire vous savez ça fait des
mois qu'on averti de cette situation des
mois qu'on se bat qu'on soutient les
confrères par tous les moyens possibles
on a même fait un système de banques
alimentaires pour les aider on y raconte
iem par les cheveux
on les accompagne bien sûr que cette
situation on l'annoncé on l'a dit on l'a
expliqué au gouvernement et on fait tout
pour essayer de résister parce que il
faut pas qu'à la faillite économique et
à la crise économique qui vont arriver
s'ajoute en plus un des drames humains
parce que je vais vous lire on peut
rebondir on peut repartir
même si c'est plus difficile en france
que dans d'autres pays mais on pourra
repartir tant qu'il ya de la vie il ya
de l'espoir
mais il faut justement pouvoir maintenir
cette possibilité d'espérance et où
est-elle l'expérience aujourd'hui vous
avez un mathieu castex notre premier
ministre avait annoncé que ce soit
l'année de la gastronomie
y'a personne tout est fermé et ensuite
il a dit mènera ce sera l'année de
l'espérance ou de l'espoir je sais plus
j'ai écouté ce serait bien qu'elle
arrive parce que si c'est comme pour la
gastronomie
ça va poser quand même un problème de
fond merci beaucoup frère eric jean-jean
secrétaire général unis 13 d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france et bon
courage à vous
le portugal à présent qui atteint lui
aussi un triste record en ce début
d'année avec 156 morts et plus de dix
mille cas de contamination pour la seule
journée du 13 janvier
vu les circonstances le gouvernement a
décidé d'appliquer à partir de demain un
confinement semblable à celui appliqué
en mars et en avril dernier
antoine auger avec solène gaudin face à
des hôpitaux au bord de la saturation
les médecins portugais réclame un
nouveau confinement
les gens doivent prendre conscience
qu'ils ne peuvent pas se réunir qu'ils
ne peuvent pas ne pas se protéger qui ne
peuvent pas être en dehors de leur foyer
familial ni en dehors du cercle de leurs
fréquentations habituelles
s'ils ne font pas cela la pandémie va
continuer à se développer et les
hôpitaux ne vont pas pouvoir faire face
et donner une réponse comme ils l'ont
fait jusqu'à présent le gouvernement qui
contrairement à ceux d'autres pays
européens n'avaient pas jugé nécessaire
en automne dernier dirt confiner le pays
a vu hier son premier ministre antonio
costa anneaux
c'est que le portugal se confine ray
complètement pour la deuxième fois à
partir du 15 janvier
restons concentrés sur la règle est la
règle c'est que chacun doit rester chez
soi il ne faut pas se laisser distraire
par les exceptions certes elle existe on
pourra toujours aller à l'épicerie faire
les achats dont nous avons besoin nous
irons à notre travail s'il le faut mais
la règle c'est de rester à la maison
c'est ça l'essentiel
dès ce vendredi à minuit les portugais
ne pourront donc plus sortir sans
attestation
seuls certains établissements seront
autorisés à ouvrir sous certaines
conditions
les restaurateurs devront quant à eux se
contentait de la vente à emporter et des
livraisons
les établissements culturels et sportifs
devront rester fermée exceptionnellement
pour le premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle le 24 janvier prochain
les bureaux de vote seront ouverts ces
mesures qui viennent ternir les espoirs
de reprise économique prenne effet pour
une période d'un mois soit jusqu'au 15
février prochain mais elles seront
réévalués après quinze jours et pourrait
prendre fin ou s'assouplir si la
situation s'améliore d'ici là la
campagne de vaccination jugé essentiel
par le premier ministre devrait se
poursuivre à travers le pays au 8
janvier dernier
70000 portugais avait déjà été vaccinées
contre le court aux navires us est
l'espagne enregistré hier un nombre
record de nouveaux cas de kobe 19 avec
trente neuf mille personnes détectées
positive en 24 heures la pression
hospitalière continue également
d'augmenter les précisions de notre
correspondante leslie singh l'a depuis
barcelone
c'est le pire chiffre enregistré depuis
le début de la pandémie en espagne les
autorités s'inquiètent car la troisième
vague pourrait donc s'accélérer
près de trente neuf mille cas c'est
trois fois plus que durant la première
vague mais attention ces chiffres aussi
reflète la hausse du nombre de tests
effectués dans le pays qui est bien plus
élevé qu'il ya quelques mois alors
néanmoins
ministre de la santé précise que la
pression hospitalière continue
d'augmenter
ce sont actuellement plus de 25 % des
lits en soins intensifs qui sont occupés
par des patients atteints par le
coronavirus il faut savoir que début
décembre c'était un peu moins de 10% de
lits et le gouvernement exclut pour
l'instant un confinement à domicile
généralisée mais des mesures sont en
vigueur dans chaque région d'espagne
il y a des couvre-feux qui sont en place
à des horaires différents selon les
communautés autonomes et par exemple en
catalogne il est interdit de quitter sa
ville de résidence
sauf pour motif essentiel alors
l'espagne a prévenu d'ores et déjà ses
habitants que les prochaines semaines
vont être très difficiles et pour en
parler nous sommes avec erwan rossé
dorado journaliste ex peigne hall
bonsoir anne heures osé dorado merci
d'être avec nous pour évoquer cette
situation malheureusement très critique
également en espagne nouveau record de
contamination le chiffre fait froid dans
le dos on l'a dit 39000 l'effet des
fêtes
effectivement c'est un chiffre qui fait
foi fois dans le dos vous voyez et
l'espagne à 20 millions d'habitants au
moins que que la france et nous avons à
peu près entre dix et quinze mille cas
décontamination des plus quotidiennement
que la france dont ce sont des chiffres
extrêmement compliqué mais c'est vrai
aussi que l'espagne ne vit pas le même
situation qu'en france dans la mesure où
par exemple les centres culturels les
théâtres les salles des concerts les les
et restaurants les bars sont ouverts ce
qui n'est pas le cas en france donc ça
pourrait aussi donc expliquer ce nombre
des cas des contaminations quotidien que
quand vous disent y ait été hier des 39
milles aujourd'hui le ministère parler
dans les 35000 lors des 24 dernières
heures et surtout ce chiffre aussi est
très important pour un pays comme
l'espagne plus des cinquante trois mille
morts on se souvient qu'en mars et en
avril dernier le confinement avait été
très strict en espagne peut-être même
plus stricte qu'en france puisque même
les enfants n'avaient pas le droit de
sortir pourquoi c'est ont autant
relâcher avec autant de permissivité par
rapport en tout cas à la france ça
revient d'avoir un restaurateur
le pauvre qui se peignaient que voilà ça
faisait des mois qu'ils étaient fermées
il n'en voyait pas le bout alors il ya
dia principalement deux raisons qui
peuvent expliquer ça donc la ligne de
raisons je dis pas la première mais
l'idée raison c'est certainement la
raison économique l'espagne est un pays
qui comme toute l'europe a beaucoup
souffert économiquement avec une perte
de chiffre d'affaires et de pib assez
importante pour pour le pays
l'espagne a donc décidé effectivement de
remettre un peu en selle les
professionnels les restaurateurs et
l'hôtel et l'hôtellerie ce qui est
toujours pas le cas du côté de la france
pour essayer dé sauver et des samples
puisqu'une espagne et est fortement
touchée et par le chômage et notamment
le chômage des jeunes et puis il ya une
deuxième raison qui est la région la
raison politique vous avez aujourd'hui
le gouvernement espagnol est un
gouvernement de coalition qui gouverne
aux minorités qui a eu fort à faire avec
les différents gouvernements régionaux
qui demandait lors du premier confirmant
avoir plus de pouvoirs pour pouvoir
gérer la pandémie et le gouvernement a
décidé lors de ce 12e cette deuxième
vague espagnol dé la pandémie est tout
simplement des
laissez le gouvernement autonome gérer
la pandémie c'est pour cela qu'ils aient
autant france on est en train de tout
concentrer autant en espagne
la vaccination par exemple est géré par
le gouvernement autonome et c'est comme
disait votre correspondante du côté de
barcelone c'est chaque région qui
détermine quels sont les secteurs
d'activités économiques qui peuvent
ouvrir ou pas et quels sont les horaires
à respecter ou pas donc à barcelone vous
pouvez avoir effectivement des des
couvre-feux qui sont établies avant 12h
et en andalousie vous avez des couvre
feux qui sont établies à minuit donc
vous voyez la raison économique la
raison politique ont fait que l'espagne
a pris un chemin différent par rapport à
la france elle a 39 milles contamination
aujourd'hui enfin en tout cas en 24
heures on disait un chiffre
impressionnant
est ce qu'on doit également à ces
variants dont on parle maintenant
quotidiennement anglais sud-africain
peut-être même japonais
effectivement mais il ya des cas qui ont
été déjà détecté en espagne que ce soit
hollande à lucic et ce soit dans les
îles baléares et dans d'autres régions
du nord de l'espagne
donc on fait très attention à cette
variante onglets qui arrivent aussi du
côté de l'espagne c'est vrai que la
vaccination en espagne marche des
piquets depuis le 27 décembre quand elle
a commencé en tout dans toute l'europe
aujourd'hui c'est un peu moins de 700
milles espagnols qui ont déjà été
vaccinées encore une fois ce sont les
gouvernements autonomes les
gouvernements régionaux qui gèrent
justement la vaccination avec comme en
france à
une priorité qui est donnée aux
personnes âgées qui vivent dans les
ehpad miss aussi bien évidemment au
personnel sanitaire qui étaient en
contact avec ces personnes et avec la
population d façon générale une dernière
question sur les vaccins vous en parliez
tout à l'heure tu commences tu as tu
passant en espagne on est à près de
600000 vacciner c'est un bon rythme pour
vous 1 24% de la population comment
réagissent les espagnols ont déjà la
première des choses c'est que les
espagnols sont favorables à la
vaccination pour la plupart et ce qui
n'était pas le cas jusqu'à il ya
quelques jours en france donc c'est vrai
quand je vous disais que c'est plutôt
les régions qui gère donc les plans des
vaccinations et donc il ya des régions
effectivement qui sont à des
pourcentages quand même assez importante
de vaccination entre 20 et 40 40 % de la
délà de la population aujourd'hui je
vous dis c'est un peu moins de 700
milles vaccinés avec un peu près un
million deux cent mille dos qui sont
déjà arrivés en espagne
en attendant qu'arrive le reste des
vaccins qui vont être envoyés et
quintais négocié par l'union européenne
merci beaucoup dorado d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france et en
allemagne est présent gala merkel ne
cache pas son pessimisme malgré un
confinement partiel en vigueur jusqu'au
31 janvier le nombre de nouveaux 99
outre rhin reste inquiétant les
autorités sanitaires et la chancelière
appelle à prendre des mesures fortes
dans les prochains jours s'ajoute à la
crise sanitaire une récession historique
de l'activité économique allemande
depuis la crise de 2009 florian lambert
touché mais pas encore coulé considéré
encore comme une bonne élève de la
gestion de la pandémie au printemps
dernier
l'allemagne est désormais frappée de
plein fouet par la pandémie covit 19
économiquement d'abord après une année
2009 un record pour la récession depuis
la crise financière de 2008
l'allemagne voit son pib reculer de 5%
mais reste sauve grâce au rebond de son
secteur industriel
l'économie allemande a chuté de 5%
l'année dernière
c'est un record dramatique le fait que
ce soit inférieur de près d'un pour cent
aux craintes que nous avions au début de
la première phase de la pandémie est une
faible consolation
côté sanitaire l'allemagne fait face à
un rebond important de l'épidémie
qu'ovide 19 sur son territoire malgré un
confinement par celle en vigueur depuis
le mois de décembre
la fermeture des commerces sont
essentielles celle des bars et des
restaurants ou autres lieux de culture
depuis le mois de novembre
l'allemagne a enregistré ce mercredi
plus de 25 mille nouveaux cas de kobe de
19 ans 24 heures 1244 décès ont
également été recensés face à ces
chiffres et à l'apparition des nouveaux
variants anglais sud africain du
coronavirus présents sur le territoire
allemand
les autorités sanitaires s'alarme et
appel à prendre des mesures conséquentes
pour la lutte contre la pandémie
jugée trop laxiste jusqu'à présent il
est possible que la situation s'aggrave
encore
il est donc d'autant plus important que
les mesures soient systématiquement
respecter nous devons éviter que ces
nouveaux variants ne se répande fabre à
6 en février ou mars nous allégeons un
peu les restrictions nous aurons second
trimestre une forte croissance comme cet
été
l'espoir donc de voir l'économie
rebondir au deuxième trimestre 2021
mais pour cela des décisions exigeante
vis-à-vis de la population devrait être
prise dans les jours prochains en gala
merkel averti les prochaines semaines
devraient constituer la phase la plus
dure de la pandémie
la chancelière s'entretiendra avec les
dirigeants des 16 länder le 25 janvier
pour tenter d'endiguer la pandémie
outre-rhin
à ce jour huit cent quarante deux mille
personnes ont été vaccinées contre le
coc vite 19 en allemagne soit 1% de la
population avec nous dans quelques
instants
jacques saint pierre nous parlera de la
vaccination contre locaux vides
dans le monde a marché gigantesque pour
les labos qui se livrent une concurrence
sans merci est aussi un outil
d'influencé unique pour les états qui
parfois les épaules et puis nous
parlerons de la cnil qui souhaite
interdire l'usagé de drones avec caméra
par les forces de l'ordre
cela jusqu'à ce qu'un cadre normatif
soit mis en place
[Musique]
le crime est tellement épouvantable que
je pense qu'une partie de l'église mais
comme une partie de la société ne veut
pas le voir de 1950 à aujourd'hui le
travail de la commission a permis
d'identifier trois mille victimes 1500
agresseurs ces chiffres sont forcément
très en deçà de la réalité puisque des
victimes sont décédées des victimes ne
peuvent pas parler peut-être ne
parleront jamais ça montre cette
tragédie qui lie à un système au tour
c'est-à-dire comment des agresseurs
ont-ils pu agresser 10/20 parfois trente
ans nous sommes loin du bout du chemin à
vous savez des institutions se réforment
lentement l'église peut-être encore plus
lentement je ne sais pas mais en tout
cas je pense que la prise de conscience
est fait de tels scandales de tels
drames de telles tragédies dans la vie
oblige à la vérité
et
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
c'est un coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent la
haine en soi vient des lignes ans
aujourd'hui on a une gauche qui est
extrêmement tous les témoins de notre
époque sont dans la grande interview
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
21h30 heure française soyez les
bienvenus en direct sur rt france si
vous nous rejoignez l'organisation
mondiale de la santé qui entame
aujourd'hui une enquête sur l'origine du
nouveau coronavirus une équipe est
arrivée ce matin à lujan berceau de
l'épidémie et ce alors que la chine
vient d'enregistrer le premier décès dû
au co vide sur son territoire depuis
huit mois les détails avec pierre issa
wyvernes la pandémie de coronavirus
frappe une nouvelle fois la chine depuis
ce mardi à près de 5 millions de
personnes sont confinées
aujourd'hui les autorités sanitaires ont
fait état du premier décès lié au virus
depuis le mois de mai dernier
un décès qui s'est produit dans la
province de hebei située dans le
nord-est du pays principal foyer de ce
regain épidémique 138 nouveaux cas
viennent d'être détectés en 24 heures le
bilan le plus élevé depuis le mois de
mars 2020 à des médecins expérimentés
ont d'ailleurs été envoyés dans la
région
beaucoup de membres de notre équipe ont
été à pékin kachkar et room qui dans le
green giang pour aider à combattre le
virus dans ces endroits
donc on a tous assez d'expérience de
première ligne et c'est dans ce contexte
que des experts de louer mais ce sont
arrivés aujourd'hui à one berceau de la
pandémie
leur but enquêter sur les origines du
coronavirus les premiers cas détectés
intéresse particulièrement les
spécialistes ils tenteront également de
comprendre comment l'homme a pu
contracter la maladie
l'idée de faire avancer un certain
nombre d'études qui ont déjà été conçus
et décidé il ya quelques mois pour nous
permettre de mieux comprendre ce qui
s'est passé l'année dernière en décembre
et cela permettra d'examiner plus en
détail les cas initiaux les cas humains
qui ont été détectées en décembre 2010 9
en regardant les marchés le célèbre
marché de one et voir ce qui s'est passé
là-bas en essayant de découvrir tout ce
qui est entrée et sortie de ce marché
dans les semaines précédant les
événements
une rixe d'après le bilan des autorités
chinoises avec près de 4700 décès
enregistrés depuis le début de la
pandémie le pays serait aujourd'hui
l'une des grandes puissances
les moins touchés au monde et face à la
virulence de la pandémie la vaccination
contre le coc vite s'accélère drôlement
plus de 30 millions de personnes ont
déjà reçu leurs injections mais ce n'est
rien à côté des milliards d'autres qui
restent à vacciner on l'aura compris ce
vaccin représente donc un marché
gigantesque pour les labos mais aussi
c'est un seul outil d'influencé unique
pour les états qui parfois les épaules
la géoéconomie les vaccins contre deux
copines on en parle tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir
[Musique]
bonsoir jacques après des débuts
laborieux notamment en france la
campagne mondiale de vaccination contre
le comider bel et bien lancé jacques oui
tout à fait comme vous l'avait dit il ya
maintenant plus de 30 millions de
personnes qui ont reçu au moins la
première injection du vaccin il ya même
des pays où on atteint 22% de la
population comme en israël mais c'est
tout à fait vrai en réalité se déroule
une concurrence féroce et pas simplement
une concurrence économique qui aussi une
concurrence en matière d' influence
politique autour de cette histoire de la
vaccination
quels sont donc ces principaux ces
fameux prétendants sur ce marché mondial
de la vaccination contre le coc vide
alors pour l'instant on en connaît trois
évidemment ce sont les trois vaccins qui
ont été homologuées en occident le
biotech kaiser le vaccin de moderna et
le vaccin d'astrazeneca
mais en réalité si vous voulez on a
beaucoup plus de vaccins il ya en
réalité 11ac simples qui vont en arriver
à maturité d'ici la fin de 2011 sur ses
onze vaccins et bien on voit qu'il y en
a trois qui sont bio tech moderna et
curve ac qui font appel à une
technologie extrêmement innovante ce
qu'on appelle la rn messager à l'opposé
il
3 les deux vaccins chinois et le projet
de vaccin indien qui eux font appel à
une technique beaucoup plus
traditionnelle celle du virus inactivé
et puis on a les autres cas où on est
haut sur des technologies qui sans être
aussi avancé que la rn messagers sont
quand même des technologies extrêmement
innovante alors à regarder leur
appellation on voit que dans certains
cas il y à des alliances
oui tout à fait alors un premier cas
d'alliance c'est l'alliance entre une
petite société de biotechnologie biogen
tech est un groupe indie rock
pharmaceutiques importants comme faille
de même chose pour modern art parce que
moderna s'est associé avec l'institut
américain des maladies infectieuses même
chose aussi pour astrazeneca qui est un
groupe anglo suédois et qui s'est
associé avec une grande université
inversement on a des cas où on a des
grandes sociétés intégrées comme johnson
& johnson qui est en fait la première
société au monde par le chiffre
d'affaires et puis on est évidemment des
sociétés d'état comme gamaleya le
laboratoire russe ou comme les
laboratoires chinois alors ce qui est
très intéressant c'est que on vérifie
tout d'abord que eh ben la taille de la
société n'est pas quelque chose de tout
à fait décisif puisque johnson & johnson
est très loin d'avoir réussi à faire
avaliser son vaccin que pfizer n'est que
le 16e sur la part dans le finder est
quatrième sur la liste et que
astrazeneca n'est que le 16e bref la
taille est loin d'être clos comment
jacques l'union européenne s'est elle
positionnée non ses commandes de vaccins
alors l'union européenne a évidemment
beaucoup aidé toutes ces compagnies elle
a passé des commandes extrêmement
importante mais à ce moment là il faut
quand même regarder deux choses l'union
européenne dit qu'elle a commandés m
yar 500 millions de doses c'est exact et
on voit les chiffres là simplement ce
qui est important de voir c'est que
d'une part des pays qui ne sont pas qui
ne font pas partie de l'union européenne
comme par exemple la grande bretagne et
israël ont accepté de payer plus cher
les vaccins et en ont obtenu plus
immédiatement le deuxième point qui est
important c'est que l'union européenne
et ça c'est peut-être une erreur par
rapport à la confiance dans la
population à accepter de dégager les
laboratoires de leur responsabilité si
jamais il arrivait des accidents dans le
cours de cette vaccination est le
troisième point important qu'il faut
toujours avoir à l'esprit c'est que sur
ce 1 milliard 500 millions de 12
et bien en fait ce que l'on va recevoir
dans les médias c'est beaucoup plus
réduit d'ailleurs il ya d'ores et déjà
eu des pénuries en allemagne on voit que
les trois vaccins qui sont homologués
pfizer biotech moderna et astrazeneca
dont dans l'homologation est en cours et
bien ça représente à peu près 760
millions de doses donc ce n'est pas 1
milliard 500 millions
et là dessus on voit que c'est très loin
d'être suffisant pour pouvoir vacciner
les 450 millions d'européens
on peut penser que d'ici à cet été il
n'y aura que 280 à 300 millions
d'européens qui auront été vaccinés et
combien coûtent ces vaccins alors là
c'est un point sur lequel il n'y a pas
vraiment de grande transparence
fiennes 1 dans ces documents on dit que
le vaccin coûterait autour de 20 euros
anne ses concurrents le russe gamaleya
dans un document qu'il a fait circuler
montre que le prix du vaccin pfizer
serait plutôt 30 euros que 20 euros
alors ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que le
prix d'un vaccin dépend de la quantité
qui est produite dans un laps de temps
donné
et donc c'est pour ça qu'on a beaucoup
de mal à savoir quel est le prix réel ça
dépend en réalité des contrats ce qui
est important c'est que effectivement
l'union européenne en s'associant 10 ans
en associant les pays qui la composent a
certainement pu négocier des prix qui
étaient des prix intéressants mais mais
elle ne va pas parce que c'est si vous
laissez commandes sont répartis sur six
laboratoires et bien elle ne va pas
pouvoir bénéficier des effets d'économie
d'échelle et vous avez montré jacques
comment cela fonctionne en europe mais
pour le reste du monde comment ça se
passe alors dans le reste du monde est
bien évidemment c'est l'espace qui est
maintenant tout à fait ouverts aux
vaccins chinois et aux vaccins russe là
dessus on voit très bien qu'il y à
développement qui est très rapide il
faut pas oublier quand même que la chine
est un important pays pour la
fabrication des médicaments et que
évidemment la russie à savoir faire dans
ce domaine qui est loin d'être
négligeable
alors jacques la question qu'on s'est
souvent posé les vaccins russes et
chinois sont ils vraiment sûr
effectivement là dessus il faut dire que
ce sont des vaccins qui pour l'instant
ne sont pas encore homologué en europe
alors les chinois ont commencé à
vacciner très tôt plus de 10 millions de
personnes sont d'ores et déjà vaccinées
la chine a commencé par vacciner ces
militaires à la prétendue la vaccination
et pour l'instant on n'a pas de
nouvelles
d'accident sérieux la russie a elle
aussi commencé à vacciner
plutôt que dans l'union européenne elle
a elle commencé en ciblant le personnel
soignant après elle est en train
d'étendre cette vaccination et on est
aujourd'hui en russie au delà du million
on était au million le 6 janvier on doit
être actuellement autour de 1 millions
2,1 millions 3 bon et là on sait qu'il
ya une d'une décision du gouvernement
qui va étendre
évidemment cette vaccination à la
totalité de la population
jacques où on
étant d'une possible coopération avec
les russes et les chinois
dans ce contexte alors sur la question
de la coopération
c'est un point qui est d'ailleurs assez
assez intéressant le laboratoire russe
gamaleya a passé un accord avec
astrazeneca au mois de décembre et dont
le cadre de cet accord astrazeneca a dit
qu'il apportait son soutien à
l'homologation du vaccin russe en europe
donc ça déjà ça prouve qu'il y a une
forme de coopération
une deuxième forme de coopération
pourrait porter sur la production même
du vaccin russe et on sait qu'il ya eu
des contacts entre les dirigeants russes
et les dirigeants allemands il ya eu un
été évoqué en particulier dans une
conversation téléphonique entre le
président poutine et la chancelière
angela merkel là dessus donc oui il y à
déjà l'amorcé d'une collaboration en ce
qui concerne le vaccin russe par contre
pour la question du chinois les chinois
font bande à part alors que représentent
les vaccins chinois et russes sur le
marché mondial alors oui grande question
évidemment c'est fanny mais vous savez
la chine c'est un milliard 500 millions
d'habitants au minimum
donc évidemment le potentiel de
production des vaccins chinois est tout
à fait énorme et compte tenu du fait que
la chine utilise son vaccin
effectivement dont des accords
politiques avec d'autres pays d'asie
mais aussi beaucoup en afrique on peut
penser que la production va monter de
manière extrêmement importante et elle
atteindra probablement les 5 milliards
de doses en ce qui concerne la russie et
bien le point important c'est que la
russie a passé des accords avec toute
une série pays
le vaccin russe est déjà homologué dans
certains de ces pays
c'est le cas en argentine c'est le cas
en algérie mais le point réellement
important c'est l'accord qui était passé
entre le laboratoire d'état gamaleya est
un laboratoire indien qui est soutenu
aussi par le gouvernement indien
pourquoi parce que l'inde affronte un
problème quand même très sérieux avec
cette épidémie 1
l'inde est un pays
un des pays les plus touchés par cette
épidémie et lalinde a obtenu de la
russie la licence de fabrication du
vaccin
donc on peut penser que le vaccin russe
sera produit à des coûts extrêmement
faibles qui sont les les coûts indien et
sera produit en très très grande
quantité
donc on peut penser que le vaccin russe
pourrait atteindre jusqu'à trois
milliards de doses dans cette année 1
pour conclure jacques ce sont donc les
grandes manoeuvres entre laboratoires et
nation si on comprend bien oui tout à
fait alors d'abord il faut dire une
chose
ça représente un exploit scientifique et
industrielle absolument hors pair on ne
pensait pas il ya un an que l'on aurait
des vaccins aussi vite donc il faut
vraiment souligner le fait que c'est un
véritable exploit
ensuite il faut peut-être rappeler qu'il
ya des gens dont on ne parle pas ou dont
on ne parle plus qui se sont beaucoup
engagé là dessus par exemple donald
trump qui avait promis aux américains
qu'ils auraient un vaccin pour noël bon
t'es plus ou moins réalisé qui a surtout
débloqué des sommes extrêmement
importantes on parle de deux milliards
et demi de dollars qui ont vraiment
beaucoup aidé les gouvernants il ya
aussi le soutien qu'ils étaient
apportées au laboratoire par les
gouvernements russe et les gouvernements
chinois qui a beaucoup compté donc ça
c'est un point important
et puis un autre point extrêmement
important c'est qu'on voit qu'il y à des
modèles industriels très différents on a
le modèle industriel de la grande
société pharmaceutique qui s'allie avec
une petite biotech beaucoup plus agile
beaucoup plus innovantes c'est par
exemple l'alliance entre pfizer et et
bio ntech on a le modèle de la grande
société pharmaceutique intégrées
johnson & johnson et puis on a le modèle
de laboratoire d'état qui après passent
des contrats de production avec
différents pays c'est le cas du russe
gamaleya où c'est le cas des
laboratoires chinois et donc ça prouve
que face à ce défi que représentait la
production d'abord la conception plus la
production des vaccins et bien
plusieurs modèles industriels qui sont
possibles il y a plusieurs types de
réponses à une même question et merci
jacques concept éclairage sur une
question qui malheureusement va être
encore d'actualité de nombreux mois je
le crains mercier vous et bonne soirée
la cnil souhaite interdire l'usagé de
drones avec caméra par les forces de
l'ordre et cela jusqu'à ce qu'un cadre
normatif soient mis en place a indiqué
avec need
aujourd'hui le conseil d'état avait déjà
ordonné en décembre de ne pas recourir
aux drones pour surveiller les
manifestations dans un communiqué le
ministère de l'intérieur prend acte de
cette décision dont il respectera les
termes et souligne que l'article 22 de
la loi de sécurité global prévoit cette
interdiction et pour en parler nous
sommes avec jean-pierre colombiès porte
parole de l'union des policiers
nationaux aux indépendants bonsoir jean
pierre percée avec nous en direct sur rt
france technique qui demande donc au
ministère de l'intérieur de cesser
d'utiliser les drones est ce que c'est
une décision vous comprenez soir de
toute façon que je ne la comprennent ou
pas elle est incontournable ses
décisions s'imposent à tous honnêtement
je trouve que l' usage ou pas des drones
avec toutes les préoccupations qui
secoue actuellement et la police et la
société consiste un débat franchement
secondaire il y avait déjà des moyens de
prendre des images de capter des images
lors des manifestations le drone c'était
un petit peu la plume sur le chapeau
mais pour moi c'est d'avoir un débat qui
est au niveau au niveau tertiaire on
sait pas du tout les des préoccupations
qui devait
occuper l'esprit de ceux qui nous
dirigent et qui le commande
donc en gros pour bien qu'on comprenne
quand même ce n'est pas une grosse perte
entre nîmes et pour les policiers
s'étaient pas un outil indispensable
non pas du tout or si vous discutez avec
des policiers de terrain croyez moi que
les sujets de préoccupation et des
intérêts sur tout autre la sécurité sur
le terrain la pérennité de leur mission
le police bashing auquel on assiste
depuis des mois maintenant depuis trop
longtemps en tout cas des discours
politiques qui sont à géométrie variable
incompréhensible au niveau du terrain et
ça c'est un problème majeur c'est
vraiment pas le drone n'est absolument
pas dans l'ordre des préoccupations de
tout à chacun
je parle des policiers vision alors le
bourreau de la sécurité doit se tenir le
25 janvier prochain vous avez participé
à écouter les associations que ce ne
sera pas le jeu représente pas du tout
un syndicat je représente une
association qui justement indépendante
politiquement et syndicalement je crois
pas savoir que le ministère de
l'intérieur est convié des policiers
ayant animé s'est dite association de
qu'on appelle communément des
associations de policiers en colère
maintenant si vous me demandez mon avis
quant à savoir quel est le sens et
l'intérêt de ce boulot je vous
répondrais très directement qu' on est
dans le cadre d'une politique
d'affichage pure et simple qui n'a à mes
yeux aucun intérêt si le au ministère où
le gouvernement de s'interroger avant
des réponses sur ce qui préoccupe les
policiers la citoyenneté
je leur envoie très simplement aux
multiples rapports de commissions
d'entretiens avec les organisations
syndicales tous les outils sont déjà sur
la table du ministère pour savoir ce qui
ne va pas ce qui ne va pas ce non
seulement au niveau de l'institution en
termes de moyens en terme de moyens
techniques logistiques et aussi en
termes de problématiques que de
relations entre la population et la et
la police on est dans de la
communication pure de mon point de vue
c'est pas du mien je vous rassure une
politique d'affichage comme on a
l'habitude maintenant des voir depuis
très longtemps depuis les débats
citoyens on discute beaucoup on parle
beaucoup des policiers attendent bien
autre chose et j'ai envie de vous dire
pas simplement des policiers quand on
parle de la police faut replacer tout
cela dans le contexte
ce qui concerne la police concerne la
citoyenneté concerne la vie dans notre
société
si on continue à déstabiliser et à
dévaloriser comme on fait depuis de trop
nombreux moi même donc pour dire de trop
nombreuses années l'institution police
c'est l' équilibre même de la société
qui est en danger
lorsque la police sera totalement
désarmé je parle pas simplement d'armes
létales mais désarmés juridiquement et
dans le sens donné à ces missions il
faudra vraiment s'inquiéter et on le
voit déjà dans les manifestations de
deux heures quand je dis manifestations
dans la façon dont s'expriment les les
gangs sur les terrains qui ne craignent
plus rien ni personne qui s'attaquent à
tout ce qui a pu sacré on parlait
récemment d'une crash mais ça fait très
longtemps que ça durait trop longtemps
aurier assortiment véritable d'impunité
du monde de la délinquance qui se targue
d'être soutenus par des groupes de
pression totalement est trop démagogique
db descendent d'ailleurs sur notre
antenne vous avez qualifié la situation
de de cirque vous êtes toujours
manifestement aussi sceptique sur cette
réforme de l'institution pour vous rien
de bon ne peut en sortir
non non pour une raison très simple
c'est que comme j'ai dit et répété et
très souvent tous assassin's creed ans
une sorte de déstructuration du service
public la problématique que rencontre la
police avec des formes différentes bien
entendu rejoint les problématiques de la
sortie publique de la déstructuration
des hôpitaux dans notre pays beaucoup
plus globalement de l'institution santé
au travers du service public et on
pourrait également ajouter à sable le
monde de l'enseignement donc tout ça est
un tout tout ça forme un tout d'une
philosophie qui maintenant plusieurs
années maintenant qui consiste à
dévaloriser l'an le système de service
public dans son ensemble et donc bien
évidemment la police n'y échappe pas on
sait très bien que certains ont des
arrières pensées de décaler le pouvoir
régalien vers soi des polices
municipales soient carrément vers des
entreprises privées de sécurité
et c'est là qu'est le vrai débat et moi
je regrette systématiquement j'ai fait
sur votre antenne je fais également au
travers d'articles auquel je participe
sur le les sites du net
au travers d'articles il y a quelque
chose qui dépasse les des sujets actuels
qui va il faut aller bien au delà on met
en avant toute la problématique devient
de ce qu'on qualifie violences
policières
on ne parle pas bien évidemment de la
violence des délinquants et c'est bien
dommage parce que je vous invite très
sincèrement à vous rapprocher des
victimes d'actes d'ultra violence et
vous verrez que le son de cloche est un
petit peu différent donc il faut
vraiment toujours avoir conscience que
sûr que nous assistons au niveau de la
santé de l'enseignement de la police et
de la justice s'inscrit dans une
dynamique pour objectif à terme de
réduire la portion congrue
tout ce qui est le service public et que
coûte cher c'est vrai mais qui rend bien
des services à bien des égards
merci beaucoup jean-pierre colombiès
porte parole de l'union des policiers
nationaux indépendants d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur arte france et c'est
la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve dans
quelques minutes pour 1 point complet
sur l'actualité
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre la peuplent
c'était une volonté collective
vous le savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit
il n'y a pas d'alternative on sort du
politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
souligne l'uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas là j'oublie
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct il y a quand
même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde la mesure
n'est pas en appartement en énerver
grenelle sentiment qu'il faut à chaque
fois se battre ils vivent parfois au
bord des routes nationales pas forcément
moins de paris mais toujours loin de
ceux qui les dirigent
moi j'adhère mâcon il passe un tour de
tracts avec toutes les grandes campagnes